[Musique]
vous arrive-t-il parfois d'être
confrontés à des complexes difficiles
les examinateurs public impressionnant
vous êtes concentré très strict et d'un
seul coup on a l'impression de me
retrouver en culotte courte
les agrée pas désagréable
alors bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle les
anglais lisons l'émerveillement n'est
pas quelque chose qui est réservé qui a
réservé aux jeunes
l'émerveillement c'est une c'est une
qualité que l'on peut toujours acquérir
extraordinaire on verra tout à l'heure
en plus que l'émerveillement peut
générer de nouveaux neurones toujours
plus confortable
toujours plus loin autre avantage c'est
que y'a pas d'âge
l'an dernier à la même époque
j'ai passé une décade tués d'ici
décembre pour ceux qui veulent arrosée
l'année dernière j'ai passé une d4 et
les décades c'est toujours une charge
émotionnelle importante
la première ville ans quand on va voir
quelle va être mon prochain téléphone
portable
déjà 20 on peut se poser des questions
bien trempé à 40 watts
j'ai passé ma huitième des cadres alors
là c'est lourd c'est lourd et en fait
tous les tous les amis qui vous disent
mais enfin mais mais pourquoi pourquoi
garder cette activité toujours apprendre
toujours transmettre
je dois dire que quelquefois j'ai même
de j'ai envie de me justifier sur
qu'est-ce que je fais là c'est vrai et
puis et puis
y'a socrates qui m'a vraiment que tout à
fait rassuré socrates à la fin de sa vie
vous voulez apprendre à jouer de la
flûte et c'est à lille mais tellement
faim socrates mais quelle idée
d'apprendre un instrument de musique
alors que tu es pas loin de la fin et
socrate répondre est juste trop amorphes
et de la flûte avant de mourir donc
finalement je me suis né mais pourquoi
tu parlais pas des merveilles manger
quelque chose qui te tient à coeur
tu as envie de le transmettre alors
l'émerveillement qu'est ce que c'est
l'émerveillement
j'ai envie de dire que l'émerveillement
c1
un élixir de jeunesse je m'émerveille
voilà et merveilles et ce regard ce
regard que je peux porter sur sur sur la
vie finalement j'ai été très rassuré
mois petite parenthèse par le fait que
les permanences et pas simplement un
état de grâce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut générer donc dans le temps
qu'ils mettent un parti on va parcours
est un peu d'enthousiasmé sous trois
angles
moi ce que j'aimerais déjà chez avec
vous lever le tabou qu'il y a sur
l'émerveillement
ensuite comment y accéder et après très
docte je vous donnerai le regard des
neurosciences sur cet automne par
veilleux alors pour se justifier déjà
pour se déculpabiliser plus si vous êtes
si vous êtes dans l'émerveillement
imaginer imaginer une réunion sérieuse
tout le monde est autour de la table
tout le monde est en costume cravate
aussi d'ailleurs mais il ya quelqu'un
qui parle d'un nouveau projet ayant fond
de la salle waouh tout le monde sortant
vers l'est peut-être que lui il a vu
beaucoup plus de d'applications
possibles mais il se rassoit
tranquillement
yuna j'étais un peu trop loin car dès
regarder votre ami einstein einstein qui
ne dit pas mieux vaut mourir que de
perdre enthousiasme je crois que il se
visualise elle en train de chevaucher
des météores lorsqu'il est en train de
travailler
j'aurais priori lines et de mc do
d'évoquer tout à l'heure prenez une aire
hubert reeves lui n'arrive toujours
espiègle émerveillé émerveillés devant
des enfants d'une école maternelle qui
sont en train de comprendre la
différence entre le diamètre du soleil
un maître de la terre
tout simplement parce qu ils leur
montrent une orange et une tête épaules
et il est fou de joie
c'est merveilleux les gens comme du
mépris l'eau mais qui sont vraiment des
passeurs des passeurs de de savoir on a
l'impression d'être intelligente on les
écoute il ya dix points connus mais s'il
a fait ce qu'il a fait quelque chose
hansson il a présenté avec une
composante très complexe la topologie
une composante très complexe de son
savoir faire et vous savez comment ils
disent on vulgariser les choses avec à
bagnols un présage une brioche nom dans
le domaine artistique
ce film now mozart que vous avez
peut-être vu si vous n'avez pas vue vous
voyez le deux mâts hummels arias isaac
stern qui se promènent conservatoire
conservatoire et une petite chinoise qui
monte sur scène qui commence à jouer du
violon très mécanique il la regarde et
lui dit chante chante la partition est
maintenant jouglar dans ta tête et joue
du violon pareil et c'est merveilleux
elle a retrouvé de fluides et
extraordinaire et isaac stern il est il
est aussi émerveillé que s'il était dans
une standing ovation au gardien alors
dévoilé un petit peu des deux mais
émerveillement le petit prince pour moi
le petit prince y musica ma vie ce
regard émerveillé sur la vie
ses yeux grands ouverts et là vous avez
une chose c'est que le petit passe
il a été sur l'astéroïde b612 et cet
aspect 612 a failli ne pas être
découvert pourquoi parce que l'astronome
qui est venu le présenter étaient en
costume de rupture qui est donc les
jambes
les grandes personnes n'ont même pas été
au delà pour aller voir ce que pouvait
apporter cet astéroïde
ils se sont simplement vie cela n'est
pas respectable années suivantes il est
venu en plastique européen et la lâcheté
héroïne d 612 a été reconnue j'ai une
petite passion oui vous le dire
j'adore j'adore les petites dans les
villes vous savez les ce qu'on appelle
des et fleur de bitume tandis que tu
aimes la nature jeu devant moi je suis
une fleur de bitume et non c'est vrai et
je me promène d'appareils photo et temps
en temps quand je vais voter la rive
mais je me cache je me cache parce que
c'est quand même pas sérieux et bien
rassurez vous c'est très sérieux
il ya un savant un chercheur de
l'université de brazzaville qui a étudié
la faune des villes il ya une variété
plus grande que dans la campagne
donc ça vaut le coup reste hervé 500
variétés différentes toutes identifiées
autre source d'émerveillement
j'accompagnais récemment un animateur
qui fait du team building avec une
sourde à ces étonnantes
c
on veut la même chose oui d'accord
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un déclic
bangkok les listes voilà donc
effectivement vous êtes dans un musée
vous passez devant leur set m'a dit vas
y
auvers-sur-oise ses cheveux cassants
c'est à peu près ce à quoi la norme
c'est simple et se disant cet animateur
dirait il prenait un groupe de 10
personnes achetant les roues devant ce
tableau pendant dix minutes pendant
trois minutes les gens résister les et
qu'est ce que je vais raconter d'un télé
on veut toujours raconter des choses
intelligentes quoi qu'est-ce que je vais
raconter là dessus je ne sais pas edit à
petit la barrière tomber leur tiens
j'avais remarqué qu'il y avait une tache
de jaune pour que l'église est de
travers où va cette petite dame au bout
de dix minutes l'animateur regrouper
tout le monde est là extraordinaire
c'est que les gens se parlaient alors
que c'était des gens plutôt tel que le
décrit verdone nous reste à l'heure des
gens très bien sur eux la seul coup il
il échangeait mais ta vie d'un type dash
shaw qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
retrouver leur âme d'enfant
l'émerveillement et donc la
communication quand on a vraiment casser
cette barrière du du concept pour voir
bien au delà la communication
s'établissait personnellement il m'est
arrivé d'être en contravention dans cet
émerveillement
mais il ya dans une librairie j'entre
dans une librairie
très digne en général j'aime bien les
librairies je verrai livre mais j'aime
bien l'auteur des librairies aussi quand
on se promène avec ma femme est ce dont
notre intérêt fort thales va y avoir une
librairie pas loin
et en fait dans un climat
j'avais été j'avais été très digne
j'arrive à la fin est la personne la
sortie me dis alors vous allez trouver
ce que vous cherchez un nom jeter un
coup d'oeil
sasken magie et qu'avez vous vu on n'est
pas à l'aise dans ces cas là c'est coup
j'ai acheté deux trois trucs pour sauver
bien des mauvais mais cette question en
fait je crois que pour atteindre à
l'émerveillement faut oublier le nom de
ce que l'on regarde en parlent en vue
lui je pense à la brume ça n'a rien à
voir c'est pas cynique
c'était métro école militaire
une petite vieille avec sa canne qui
cherchait la première marche avec sa
canne blanche
je lui donne le bras on descend les
escaliers de venir mener moins au début
de la ram jeux dessins opéra je lui dis
je suis désolé je l'espère je pourrai
pas vous accompagner mad money mais ça
aucune importance je connais
parfaitement l'année toujours est-il en
bas et d'un seul coup elle s'arrête
elle me regarde elle me dit on est
arrivé mais avec je serai à l'été
réalité vraiment triomphante alors que
moi je me proposais de l'accompagner
c'est elle qui m'avait accompagnée ils
sont regarde le regard d'évènements je
ne sais pas si je peux finir c'est pas
défini cela c'est quelque chose qui
vient vraiment du coeur c'est chouette
notre exemple mon père est un peu comme
ça il avait une sorte de de savoir-faire
pour détecter les signaux faibles
d'émerveillement et en faire des feux
d'artifice puis je suis bénévole dans un
centre de soins palliatifs dans la zone
de support palliatifs on accompagne les
gens en fin de vie et ne croyez pas que
ce soit triste moi je dis souvent que je
vais faire mon plein d'humanité
mais au printemps des gens comme étaient
dans leurs champs pendant très longtemps
rêve d'aller dans le jardin on est
équipé par le faire on sort les lie avec
l'oxygène avec les perfs et où je me
souviens d'un monsieur qui était sous un
arbre jetaient sur les feuilles bougeait
et ce type qui avait encore pour deux
trois jours était dans un émerveillement
que je ne saurais même pas vous décrire
alors il ya des il ya des casseurs dont
vraiment des casseurs d'émerveillement
ça existe comment les définir
c'est les gens qui savent elles et les
gens qui savent voilà je sais donc
l'émerveillement dangereux ce n'est pas
pour moi c'est un peu quelques fois vous
a aidé ça se voit encore dans certaines
rencontres
il ya des messieurs très digne qui a la
cinquantaine se présente encore donnant
leur nom de l'école et leur est sortie
de l'apple topo ils sont bâtis une
personnalité sur des connaissances il
avait acquis sportivement partie habite
encore chez leurs parents
mais le parcours est long quoi de le le
casseur d'émerveillement sais c'est le
pain ou aqua blue et regarde ses fleurs
tu as pu choisir vers la commune est
attentionné il fait son centre
ça casse tout alors l'idée à lider ça
serait vraiment d'arriver d'arriver sur
sur le web ou quoi enthousiasme alors
comment comment j'allais dire comment
aller vers l'émerveillement ça me gêne
un peu parce que c'est quand même à
l'état détaillent être mais il ya des
techniques quand même on verra après
l'aspect nos scientifiques dans
l'émerveillement il ya une chance est
d'être vraiment dans la minute présente
être présent c'est vraiment tous ses
sens tendus vers un même objectif est un
exercice dans la grande évasion la
méditation d'exercice du grain de raisin
la méditation la dominer de l'instant
présent ça a été tu donnes kabat zinn en
amérique qui a développé sa danse 150
hôpitaux on pratique cette méditation en
france christophe andrieux donc la
grande réserve pro ne vous en prenez une
poigne pointe là le cet exercice je vais
vous le faire un peu rapide mais cela
prend 10 minutes mais ça consiste à
mettre tous ses sens au service de
l'homme du regard sur un vrai si vous le
mettez dans votre main ou sortait son
poids lourds
regardez tout l'esprit d'urs sous tous
les angles ou découvrir les merveilles
de grève ou le prenez pas dans la leçon
je le met dans la bouche un tout petit
peu qu'elle je suis va sortir me sentais
un peu tout cet émerveillement qui peut
monter ça va même jusqu'à ressentir
l'envi d'avaler sa d'exercice alors un
autre exercice qui est assez sympa j'ai
trouvé ça dans une nationale pour
enfants
des journaux pour enfants est absolument
génial c'est regarder avec un autre
regard je vous conseille de le faire
d'essayer de le faire c'est vous vous
promenez votre regard tombe sur une
bouteille à votre demeure et vous
changer à chaque fois jamais jamais le
nom de ce que vous voyez alors les pour
les adultes c'est très difficile des
enfants font ça facilement en revanche
pour un adulte c'est difficile mais ça a
un avantage c'est que ça va ça va un peu
tourner voulait tourner à brûler le
cerveau on sait plus où il en est on
sait plus qui regarde c'est regarder
fois leur égard des neurosciences sur le
phénomène
alors on a quatre cerveau j'ai pas le
chapeau pour le dire mais le premier le
premier sert au sein du cerveau at-il
entre les anciens qui est vraiment leur
extérieur qui a su relation vu notre
propre survie
à l'étagé au dessus le paléo limbique le
panier olympique
disons il est là pour la survie du
groupe
la note le pouvoir l étage au dessus
sont les deux cerveaux qui nous
intéresse un type de gouvernance pour
voir la bascule entre ce que je suis
quand je suis dans le vrai quoi on va
passer dans le web
notre héritage au dessus il y a le néon
la vie que le nehalem-ex est le cerveau
de l'enregistrement de l'apprentissage
et des merveilleux pour tout ce qui est
simple les habituels complexité et à
l'étagé au dessus le prêt frontale qui
lui prend le recul nécessaire et apte
dix ans à saisir tout ce qui est
inhabituel ce qui est complexe
comment ça marche donc en gros si vous
êtes face à la complexité difficulté
préfrontal si vous êtes face à la
répétition j'ai pas le feu passe au
rouge vous venez ya par da silva
thiesson préfrontal nous diriez à tient
ce feu rouge il un peu moins rouge comme
d'habitude et la pompe sayah ces
accidents donc le lundi est vraiment
alors comment il fonctionne celle
indique comment il fonctionne il est
automatique
donc il est dans l'habitude ça vous
connaissez des gens comme ça dans les
procédures de changement
on a toujours fait comme ça c'est bien
résistance non ne m'en parlait plus
vraiment je suis à l'aise avec sa
dualité ses plans ou c'est noir dans
l'incertitude les gens qui ont des
certitudes passage je suis absolument
certain ya même pas la peine de
réfléchir empirique l'empiré qui n'a
jamais lu un mode d'emploi il essaye
l'appui surtout les plus tôt en
instaurant ça passe l'image sociale les
matchs social ce qu'il bouffe un maximum
c'est que vous pensez les autres que
vont penser les autres
si je manifeste mon événement que mon
penser les autres et je me rassois donc
le cerveau adaptatif vous voyez à
l'écran d'ailleurs que les eaux ne sont
pas les mêmes activé avant la partie
gauche c'est la zone 10 dont une
indiquant jaune qui est activé et la
partie du prêt frontale en bleu donc
l'earl adaptatif il est curieux il veut
il veut vraiment tout voir c'est
vraiment le joli 5e
certains certains scientifiques quelques
face aux riches vis de leurs de leur
échec même parce qu'il ya une curiosité
stade théry cheikh c'était chouette dans
sa tête il est curieux naturellement il
est il accepte de l'anglais adaptatif la
dualité toni n'existe pas rien des
blancs rien n'est noir il ya toujours de
la nuance à pouvoir travailler
aucune certitude du pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi un poil sur la question et
enfin il est libre il a une opinion
personnelle c'est à dire c'est moi voilà
ce que je pense et j'ai pas besoin de
balayer toute la salle pour savoir si
j'ai le droit d'exprimer ce que je pense
alors c'est le docteur jacques fradin
qui est un disciple de la borie qui a
été examiné les deux les deux
gouvernance la gouvernance automatique
et la gouvernance adaptative et pourquoi
j'ai repris cette c2 gouvernance c'est
qu'en fait dans le passage sur
l'émerveillement où il passe
spontanément où on peut l'aider en
essayant de changer sa gouvernance en
appel la gestion des modes manteau et
une passe kull une bascule de l'un vers
l'autre
pierre marie pierre marie lledo
difficile à prononcer il est responsable
de des neurosciences à l'institut
pasteur
il a fait ce qu'il a fait des
interventions de notre très intéressant
mais il dit surtout surtout que
stimulation égard production de nouveaux
neurones
on vient je boucle avec dillon élixir de
jeunesse des nouveaux neurones et à
chaque fois que je suis disons dans le
changement ya production cdu souche qui
convoiteraient des niveaux de monde ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si je ne
peux pas basculer naturellement je vais
essayer de voir sur quel sur quels prêts
frontalité je suis est-ce que je suis
sûr préfrontal est-ce que je suis sur le
thématique c'est facile à dire si vous
êtes en train de me dire de vous dire ce
que je dis que je disais nous fait pas
comme ça j'en suis sûr inquiétez-vous
qui était aussi quelqu'un vous le dis ne
lui en veuille et parme et essayer de le
faire basculer sur quelque chose de plus
souple de plus adaptatif lorsqu'il des
huit c'est que le cerveau se détruit de
la routine et se nourrit du changement
s'inspire se détruit de la routine est
vraiment se nourrit du changement l'omi
notre ami dalaï lama des effectivement
vaut mieux que les spéciaux versé comme
les parachutes d'été et pierre-marie ari
germano insistait et sa conclusion dans
une conférence c'était la solution est
dans l'émerveillement perpétuel il ya
quelqu'un qui vient d'écrire un livre
c'est que me rappelle bertrand vergely
bertrand vergely avec réaliste c'est le
retour vers l'émerveillement et
terminait d'ailleurs je pourrais bien
terminer sur cette phrase à nous le
disait si vous êtes riche mais vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous émerveiller
êtes pauvre vous passez à côté de
l'essentiel vous manque et la beauté du
monde
la richesse des êtres humains et la
profondeur de l'humanité
[Applaudissements]